foreign
let's go out to where my parents live in
Abilene Texas and talk to Tracy what's
up Tracy
hey
we're out here
Tracy is this Tracy Tracy this is Tracy
Tracy oh mark
Tracy Tracy Tracy
how in the world are you I'm doing great
how are you
you've known me for a long time and I'm
I'm speechless right now
I'm excited
[Laughter]
oh man all right so for people the rest
of y'all listening
um
Tracy how would you classify
Tracy ran my life
for years
um and Tracy was had a like on this show
and in just in books and where I've
talked about just
um melting down like uh being doubled
over with anxiety and just really
melting and having to figure my way back
out Tracy had a ringside seat to that
you watched it real close up and Tracy
is one of the people that I credit with
being the tether that kept me held to
reality when things got real thin and
scary so I could tell with your voice
Tracy
good gracious it's so good to hear from
you
me too I'm excited to talk to you oh man
all right what have you done now just
kidding what are you up to
well I just um had a hard day the other
day and I said I'm gonna just write all
this down and see if I can get some help
and then I got a call so I was like oh
that's a different than I expected
well number one thank you for
um reaching out and two you can always
just call my cell phone you're in the
you're in my inner circle you're in my
super Inner Circle uh yeah I'm only here
because you were in my life and made
sure I was fed and watered for a couple
of years so all right so uh what's going
on how can a hill
well I have an adult child 27 years old
um she came a little later in life
there's 10 years separation between her
and her older siblings
because she was a baby I knew she was
going to be my last child and I kind of
ruined her I spoiled the heck out of her
um which I enjoyed every second of it
and I had people telling me all the way
hey hey you're not doing the right thing
give me an example
what do you mean I never said no I just
figured there's a way we can make
everything
we can make everything happen we can
make everything work
she's super smart talented Charming
highly capable so I followed everything
went to everything encouraged everything
paid for everything whatever you need we
got it you know just
just everything
and so what happened recently that sets
you off well it's been it's been a
little while but it just seems like
maybe the veil has been lifted from in
front of me and I'm seeing it a little
different
um
she has a little bit of a tendency to
self-sabotage so she never really gets
to the success level so she can see what
that feels like or enjoy that which
always leaves are kind of in a mess
and what does she get when she gets in a
mess
well some she quit quits her job or gets
fired no no underneath her what does she
get
I don't know attention maybe
I can think other than my wife and two
or three of my closest friends
this is just me talking to my friend
right now
I can think of a few oh crap Tracy I'm
gonna get all choked up I can think of
few people in the world
that have more have had more of a
positive impact in a one-on-one just
listening and making me feel like
everything was going to be okay then you
you did that for me personally right at
about her same age right
and if that's what you get for getting
fired
I'd get fired every other week
I had to stay employed to get that with
you
me too yeah exactly
that meant you had to make sure both of
us were still employed so if that's what
she gets if she gets some special
one-on-one time with an extraordinary
listener and an extraordinary encourager
and extraordinary it's gonna be okay
we're gonna figure it out
then the
the like what I don't know why I would
need anything else everyone's pushing me
to get these other things that's what I
want because that's incredible
well and I love it I love spending the
time I love being the ear that listens
and the hug that Comforts I love doing
that
but things have kind of shifted a little
bit to being um
no longer really
uh thankful or appreciative more like uh
kind of an O we owe it ah okay the
financial help the drop what you're
doing you know I'm coming I'm staying
stay up all night even though we have to
get up and go to work or you know just
things are just different and
I don't want to break down the barrier
of being the one that
does the safety net or the
comforting hug I don't want to break
that at all I just don't know the best
way to help
and still protect us
how's this affecting husband
uh he's he loves me and he says he'll do
whatever I want to do but I'm sure you
know if I'm feeling some anxiety about
it he's got to be feeling some too
if it was just me and him having a drink
out there in West Texas what would he
tell me
I could probably say she needs to put a
stack to this
right and he'd tell me that too I hung
out with him so does the name Dr Henry
cloud ring a bell
I I don't think I know who Henry cloud
is okay him in a guy named John Townsend
wrote a book long ago called Boundaries
he's a psychologist and
um I'm gonna quote him because I love
the way he says it he says it real
direct and here's what he said
he said
in your situation what your daughter
needs more than anything in the world
she knows you love her and she knows you
will be there for her
but she needs more than anything if she
needs some problems
because the one person she doesn't know
will show up for her is her
because that person's never had to
and the way we get problems is we sit
down usually with our significant other
and we say okay we're going to implement
some boundaries here and it's gonna
really be uncomfortable for everybody
and she'll kick and scream and say you
don't love me and you're leaving me out
to dry and I can't believe you abandoned
me and all that and you as a grown-up
will have to deal with how bad that
hurts because you know that's not true
and what you have to transition from now
is a it feels good right now it like it
feels really awesome this evening to
have her come home and hug and to make
dinner and to just listen to her because
she's hilarious
and think I'm aiming for a 35 year old
functional adult
right did his bringing their paid for a
car over to my my driveway
or they're they're driving me around in
their nice car that they paid for to
help me find a good retirement home for
me right
yeah so
ultimately it's sitting down and saying
something along the lines of and I I
honestly at this at this stage at 27 I'd
put it in writing and that may be overly
dramatic which I have a flare for for
the over dramatic but I'd probably put
into writing like
you are always welcome at our house but
at midnight we lock the doors you can't
come in can't wake us up
from this point forward we don't we're
not giving you any more money outside of
X or Y or Z or here's five thousand
bucks and this is it
um
if you get fired from your job I will
sit in the back porch and I will
commiserate with you I'm not giving you
money I'm not making another call for
you you're gonna have to figure out what
happens next if you want to move into an
apartment you can move to an apartment
um
this may be a weird question when you
were young
did you get hung out to dry
um
not exactly okay
that's the most Tracy answer
did you have to figure things out at a
real young age oh yes very young
how do you think so how young
15. okay
do you remember that not being fun
or a lonely or isolating or scary
I remember it being challenging
but now that I know myself I think I
like challenges but maybe I like
challenges because I figured things out
I don't know
but I don't remember hating it
I think that might be the greatest gift
you give her
it just is 12 years later then you got
it
so imagine a world where you say I love
you no more money
I love you you can't live here anymore
or you got you got three months you got
to find your own apartment you gotta
find your own place I don't even know if
she's living with you whatever but
whatever boundaries you draw
um
you got to pay your own car insurance
and your own cell phone bill you're 27
years old for crying out loud and you
can tell her I've already uh had to
babysit one other 27 year old years ago
named John and I'm not doing it again
I'm doing it again
um
what happens after that
I don't know what happens how good
things happen I know down the road but
you have a picture of like that
conversation does she hear that well and
go you're right it's time for me to like
how would that conversation go
um she's probably gonna get mad at a
storm away and I don't remember for a
while okay and then she slams the door
and walks out and your husband looks at
you walk me through what you would feel
right then because it's happened before
I would feel crushed and I would cry but
also probably relieved
she's not a child she doesn't need our
safety debt she needs to figure it out
on our own but it would still crush me
what
um
what if I told you she doesn't get a
vote
does that sound like like gobbledygoot
counseling nonsense
no that's why I called it doesn't sound
like nonsense
so I had this experience right after
after
um
right after I moved out from moved from
the the city where we worked together
and I took my next job uh Hank I think
was still two and a half maybe maybe
three and
as long as I live I won't forget this
moment
I walked in the front door and I saw
Hank in the in the in
the hallway little bitty kid
um and I said
come here Bubba and I I had my backpack
on and I crouched down to to be at eye
level with him and he looked at me and
he said no daddy and he took off running
down the hall in my first thought was
because you suck at being a dad
maybe if you were here and you weren't
taking more graduate classes after
you're already done with grad school and
maybe if you would just and I just
started I create this whole story
and I told Sheila and told my wife and
her first response it was was
John the only game you play with him is
Chase
he's trying to that that's how he knew
how to connect with you
and that was the first like
oh man I missed it and then as I went
down that rabbit hole I got to thinking
why have I given my two and a half year
old a voice into how I feel
he's my kid he doesn't get to dictate
that my wife does two or three of my
closer friends do you in my life Tracy
did right like will you get permission
to speak into my soul right like why
would I give that to my kid
my kids are emotional I'm their parent
right so it comes back to saying
practicing that oh you don't get a vote
if your husband tells you hey you're
being a terrible person well we need to
have that conversation if two or three
of your close friends tell you that we
need to have that conversation if your
kid tells you it hurts it stings
that you don't get a vote I'm moving
here I'm doing this right and I think
the magic word for me has been that's
something I have to practice it's just a
skill set I don't have
right
but it's gonna be awful I hate to tell
you that it won't be fun
I've been practicing it in my mind I
know
can you practice it in real life
I don't know
it's part of the game okay that's where
I would really challenge you I've got to
do it right now
I would challenge you and your husband
on that one I think setting it up and
going out to that Cracker Barrel out
there and saying here's what's gonna
happen now
because it takes it out of the immediacy
and we have to fire this thing off and
it's much more intentional and you own
you hold all the cards
you are setting up a breakfast you are
setting up the new boundaries you are
handing over a sheet of paper here's how
we're going to honor and love you and
you can say that we don't love you if we
don't give you everything you want but
this is going to be the new reality
because we have to let you fly on your
own you gotta learn how to do it
and so
um that makes it less immediate and if
if she fires back with what about this
what about this what about this the
response has got to be that's a great
that's a great question I'll think about
that
we'll holler back at you I'm not going
to give you a right answer right now
because that's not the point of this
conversation this conversation is to let
you know from this point forward here's
what the boundaries are going to look
like
it just takes that immediacy out of it
like that frantic oh I gotta do it right
now okay you can stay
and now we're like oh crap now you're
staying or I'll give you a thousand
bucks just just don't do anything stupid
um it keeps it takes all that away
how's that sound
's okay hard yeah
how about this here's my promise
you think she'd call into the show after
you'll have that conversation and tell
me how much she hates me
I don't know
all right
here's the deal you text my private cell
number after the conversation
and if she throws a fit and goes ba in
anas
um
you can offer tell her John will talk to
you and
um I'd love to have her version on the
show too
okay
there's no chance she'll do that but
that would be awesome if she did Tracy
that would be awesome I would love to
hear the other side of it too because I
know there's two sides
I don't know I don't know about with you
you're one of the few good ones
so hey Before I Let You Go in front of
all these people they're listening
can I just tell you thank you for
being right or die with me when I was
falling apart
like for real absolutely I'm really
really grateful
thank you for letting me be there
oh come on dude for free are you for
real I told you that story about the
time uh
we were having to make some really tough
budget cuts and included a lot of
personnel positions and one day we were
driving me and my wife and she goes oh
yeah hey John I can't believe I forgot
to tell you and I wrote turned the
window down I was like what and she goes
if you cut Tracy's position I'm leaving
you and I was like whoa I was like why
and she goes she looked at me and her
and she like moved her finger back and
forth and she's like because us we only
work because of her and I just remember
thinking
that's exactly right so on behalf of
everyone this show is being even
possible
who
thank you for being that stirring at the
end of my crazy balloon that was
floating off the outer space that kept
me Tethered to the ground
um and thank you for honoring Me by by
calling in on the show
um
you've got my cell number you call me
anytime day or night and um
I love you I'm so so grateful for you
and if I can help any other way holler
back at me we'll have you back on the
show and love to have your daughter on
on the show as well you guys are awesome